new music video Friday Taylor Swift
Troye Sivan do Lolita and the other
tracks to bump this weekend plus mary j
blige gets her star on the hollywood
walk of fame hey guys guess who could
dream company again me you it is the
perfect time to get jacked up on some
caffeine because it is the end of the
week which means it is new music Friday
and if you thought last week was fire
today there are so many music videos
that got me jumping off the walls or
maybe it's this alright thanks Rick yep
that's enough of that
alright the number one video trending on
YouTube Taylor Swift of course she
dropped the globe-trotting video for
endgame last night and says if the 28
year old discovered alcohol for the
first time I'm here for it
[Music]
my usual shiksa truth
[Music]
Taylor is partying it up with edge here
in a future from Miami to Tokyo and
London and we here at et online did some
investigative work and counted about six
different drinks Tay is sipping on
throughout the video but that wasn't the
only end game Easter Egg no the Swift
these were quick to point out that Tay
Tay takes aim at her haters like Kim
kardashian-west who famously referred to
her as a snake by dropping in multiple
snake references like when she's
literally playing snake on her phone and
yeah didn't think she would be drinking
so much in this video and not use a
snake straw to sip it at one point
Taylor is even rocking a snakeskin suit
while casually sightseeing in Tokyo on a
motorbike now this is a level Petty I
aim to be at in life anyway I love this
video and you know less Taylor
choreography and more Taylor partying
with their friends is my vote
now here's who I don't mind doing full
choreo do a Lipa my thirst for dua is
real and she is keeping me hydrated with
her new music video for I don't give a
bleep a masterful visual about self-love
I just can't get enough of cut you off I
don't need to so you can try all
your time is up I'll tell you I tell you
[Music]
come on the concept inventive the
styling beautiful this video is bloody
brilliant
and there are a lot of folk out there
who seem to agree because the video
wrapped up 1 million views in just six
hours after do it Unleashed it on the
world I mean while choice of on debuted
his new single my mind my this weekend
with it a slick and sexy video that if
I'm being honest coming a little shook
[Music]
okay don't hurt him Troy my my my is the
lead single off his upcoming album
currently due out this spring Troy will
also be making his SNL debut on January
20th with post Jessica Chastain so watch
out for that I said what do you guys
think we pulled the community on which
video you guys are digging the most and
so far Taylor Swift endgame is your top
pick but keep the votes coming I gotta
say there is so much good music that
just dropped out we don't have time to
cover but quick shout out to Camilla
Kibeho she's celebrating the release of
her debut album and I've been bopping
around too into it also Carrie Underwood
has a new song with Ludacris of all
people called the champion so these
would be on repeat this weekend for me
but let me know what you guys are
listening to tweet me at D director
alright before we sign off fresh off her
two Golden Globe nominations mary j
blige a--'s legacy was literally
cemented in hollywood as the singer
received her star on the Walk of Fame
and on her birthday no less I was there
for the exciting
[Applause]
[Music]
I feel awesome I'm so happy I'm so
blessed 2018 is come in with a bang or
or hollow scream it's loud I want to
thank God for this moment because it
doesn't have to be like this Mary I want
you to enjoy this you came from Yonkers
Westchester New York you had a dream
back down looking this is you 1992 right
around the same time or your debut album
he will leave oh yeah that's right this
is my baby right here what advice you
have for that youngin right there you're
beautiful love yourself people love you
there's been times that I in my career
that I didn't even want to step out my
house because I was hurt so bad but God
gave me the strength I'm so grateful
that on this born day today is my
birthday January 11 God has put my name
on a star a star we already knew Mary is
the queen of hip-hop and R&B and it's
been amazing to watch Mary get her dues
as an actress in fact last night she was
also at the Critics Choice Awards where
she was nominated for her work in mud
bound and apparently they surprised her
with the birthday cake you guys want to
make sure you check out the five moments
you didn't see on TV at the Critics
Choice Awards up on our site now all
right guys that's it for this week and
we'll be observing MLK Day Monday so
enjoy the long weekend and we'll see you
guys on Tuesday Cheers
[Music]